personal agenda for this meeting if the
situation in Mali the agendas adopted a
virtual meeting of the UN Security
Council the 15 ambassador's taking part
remotely to discuss the situation in
Mali where violence continues to
intensify in the north of the country in
the town of bambor at least 25 soldiers
from the Malian army were killed in one
attack this week on the outskirts of the
capital Bamako this is a camp for those
displaced by the fighting the head of
the UN mission in Mali is predicting
that the impact of kovat 19 will make
things even harder in the country the UN
currently has about 15,000 peacekeepers
serving in Mali here and in all the
other peacekeeping operations around the
globe the UN faces real difficulties
soldiers who normally be relieved and
rotated back home are stuck in place for
now how worried are you about keeping
the peacekeepers that are so needed in
place yeah this is a top priority for
the for the UN there has been a
three-month freeze on rotations since
the outbreak of this pandemic to I think
really give everybody a chance to assess
what's happening and to avoid
inadvertent spread by peacekeeping
rotation I mean the key thing is that
the UN are able to bottom out really
quickly what the medical services that
they can ensure are in place for
peacekeepers and frankly for country
teams staff and other staff the UN has
now stopped all troop rotations between
now and the end of June because of the
spread of kovat 19 they have another big
worry too there are swirling rumors that
some nation
maybe considering taking all their
peacekeepers home that would be a
nightmare scenario if one country did it
others may well follow suit James BAE's
al Jazeera at the United Nations